Let's go next to our caller from the 3 0 9.
Area code caller from 3 0 9.
What's your name?
And of course, where are you calling from?
Very important details.
Hi, David, this is Sam from Texas.
Hey, Sam, what's up?
Yeah, so I'm a Bernie supporter who will be
voting Biden in November.
OK.
I talked to a fellow progressive on Facebook.
He was quoting some novel, never Biden stuff.
And thankfully, the viewer of your show and
a member, because I use some of the arguments
value brought up how Biden is more helpful
to the progressive movement.
And he actually said he was warming up to
that idea, but he brought up something really
interesting.
I think you could ever get prospected on.
He said he can't vote Biden because of his
past policies and how a lot of the previous
votes in the Senate sort of contradict the
current platform or his appeal to progressive
values.
Right.
And he said that a lot of like his past policies,
like glycolysis Trump.
So I guess those like people who want to convince
Senator Biden people to vote for Biden.
How do you convince Rand, like, how do we
help him reconcile that?
Listen.
It's a matter of this is simply a matter of
days.
Do you want to win?
And do you want to reduce harm by getting
Trump out?
Trump was pro-choice for 68 years of his life.
He completely transparently said and it was
it was transparently dishonest when he said
as he was becoming a Republican candidate.
Oh, I am pro-life now.
I'm against abortion.
Abortions, terrible jail.
The doctors jail.
The mother is right, like he said, every crazy
thing.
And the evangelicals said, we're going to
vote for the guy, because that's what he says
his policy is now.
And we at least somewhat credibly believe
that this is how he will govern.
And he has Donald Trump spoke to them.
You know, the march for life or whatever and
whatever the case may be with Biden, the policies
are more complex than simply are you for or
against abortion?
There is no question that Joe Biden in the
80s and 90s was running a more conservative
platform as senator than he is espousing for
2020.
But this is just the this is how things work.
People don't have you know, there's this idea
that has become popularized with Bernie Sanders
that if you have the same idea for 40 years,
the same position for 40 years, it's objectively
better.
Forty years is a long time.
And things change during those 40 years.
Many of the people who in the last five years
have become large advocates, strong advocates
of LGBT rights 20 years ago.
We're probably pretty homophobic by today's
standards.
And if that's going to be the standard, we'll
just lose.
I mean, it's like I would say we're just gonna
lose if that's the case.
Is Biden going to do everything he claims
he's going to do?
Of course not.
Just like Bernie wouldn't be able to.
Just like Trump hasn't been able to.
But that seems like a very poor reason that
put Biden's policies have changed.
Therefore, we want Trump to win.
It seems crazy to me.
Yeah.
No, I 100 percent agree, and I also tried
bringing up to him that I think Biden will
keep people around him that will kind of like
it.
I think the people of bino keep around him
are going to have to be pushing for his progressive
values.
And I also tried explaining how, you know,
AOC or someone like that or progressive has
a better chance of meeting with Biden to discuss
policy than they do with meeting with Trump
to discuss.
You know what I mean?
Of course.
Of course, in a Biden presidency.
The AOC wing at least will get a voice and
a hearing.
They might be well ignored.
Ninety eight percent of the time.
But with Trump in the White House, they don't
even have they don't even get a hearing.
They have zero voice.
You're absolutely right, Sam.
In fact, you know, Trump campaigns on actively
hating those values.
That's right.
So I listen, this is such a ridiculous position
in my opinion.
Sam, you do it.
You're not falling for it.
Which I think is good.
Yes, absolutely.
Good.
All right, Sam, excellent to hear from you
very much appreciate the phone call.